kyle muller goes to the mound seeking
his third big league win
and see if he can finish off robles with
pitch number six and he just did strike
three called that's how the game starts
and the first pitch whacked towards
second and ozzy with a deflection to
himself makes the play
pitch
and a swing and a miss
mueller two strikeouts
last start was august 1st against the
cubs who received a no decision in that
6-5 win three runs on four hits over six
innings struck out eight the second
highest total for him this year
gonna lay one down fetty two it in a
hurry
and knew he had to be in a hurry
and a missile to the left that's nick
greenlight too
first atlanta hit smooth easy stroke for
solaire there goes the no hitter for
fetty one on one out
and he shoots this ball down the third
baseline that's a thing of beauty
they all count
swing and a broken back pop into left
field that's gonna drop
the throw is gonna come into second
everybody's safe riley breaks his bat
and the braves have three straight hits
frames cannot let fetty off the hook in
his first inning
and he was swinging and he's got a base
hit one run scores big hop freeman
around third here comes the throw to the
plate it's not cut off duvall comes
through green light 3-0 bj was right in
the braves lead two to nothing 3-0 you
got to be aggressive man you got to take
your chances because you're hitting six
in the lineup
and there duval does his best work in
those situations great job not trying to
do too much pitch on the outer half of
the plate he drives it to right field
two rbi and that's the key
don't try to do too much in that
situation sometimes guys get too big
adam duvall did not right there and the
nets have their first base runner
as the rookie walks the number seven man
with gerardo parra about to step in
lefty lefty
whoa
it's a good take
not much problem getting to second for
trace pereira on that one
and it's hitting to right solaire coming
on
dives and he
came up
great catching right by solaire to take
away a hit from parra
tagging on the play as pereira he moves
up for the first out
oh my there's another wild pitch
that's barrera can sprint home on that
one
i'd say he manufactured the run there
but i think the pitcher did you start
doing this
as a young pitcher on a big stage in
front of 40 000 people
you know where i'm going with this give
you the yips yeah this is the brick and
kiel like and this is how he started
kyle muller
issued a lead off walk through two wild
pitches and that cost him
the only washington run the nationals
who do not yet have a hit
got some good stuff but wow and now you
got to swing at that pitch and for the
nats it works out escobar gets it down
the line digging for two
and his former teammate tried to throw
him out couple of kansas city guys there
and escobar smiles his way to a double
and the nationals have two on for carter
kibum
kibum levels off and ties the game with
a drive to left
escobar motoring home
long throw by duval
and carter kibum now is 12 for his last
29. a nice piece of hit another slider
i mean he has completely abandoned the
fastball and carter kibum was paying
attention look at him go down and get
that stand through it good extension and
a clutch knock to tie this one up
to two as you score as we move to the
fifth inning
look out
and then the next one hits para on a
breaking ball
and now that one gets away i'm telling
you man that
i would be concerned if i was
in atlanta brave right now
well outside and going to third safe
gerardo parra stealing third base
veteran move there probably thinking the
battery's so worried about where the
pitch is going i'm rolling
now fenney swings and loops one of the
air to left center going back on it
duvall trying to get in position to
throw it makes the catch para tagging
here comes the throw it'll be way late
not in time
it's a sacrifice flying a run batted in
for eric fetty it's his first of the
year and the stolen base looms large
after the hit batsman and the wild pitch
rage led two to nothing now they trail
three to two
catchers interference i think so
tres pereira i think got the glove up
and that's what caused the soft contact
so solaire will reach on
an e2 catcher's interference
so freddie golf's one to left that keeps
the ending alive
catcher's interference and a single by
freddy who's got two knocks tonight he's
up to 23 of them now and a shot into
center field there's the base hit here
comes solaire we are tied freeman to
third it's a 3-3 game
not trying to hit the home run
just going the other way got jammed it
just shows how strong raleigh is but i
love the aggressiveness early in the
count he's looking to swing the bat
and solaire takes off good jump
easy score rbi single
riley takes off little dribbler hit
toward keyboard with third farehand try
save
and his hot hitting continues
how many times do we talk about putting
the ball in play in big situations
dansby struggled
early on with strikeouts right here a
big infield hit the one-two pitch
breaking ball hammered in down the line
fair that's gonna score riley swanson on
his way to third throw to second will be
late
a two-strike hit for duvall you see the
curve ball middle of the play but down
keeping the head on staying behind the
baseball
a beautiful swing a short compact swing
rbi
74-75 and he took that slotted for a
first strike and he knew he was going to
come back with that at some point
so chris martin is the scheduled hitter
but max freed is going to bat for him
how about that
and five rbis and this one shot toward
the gap in left center field that ball
might get down
that's a double for max free
and that is exactly why i sneaked
through him up there to pitch it because
he could swing them back
jammed the big right-handed hitter long
way for para foul ground sliding and he
makes a fantastic play
enemy territory nobody to help him
luke jackson
is the next atlanta pitcher as we head
to winning number seven
swinging to miss jackson takes care of
the leadoff man luis garcia won out
that one wasn't tipped and jackson has
struck out the last two
nationals hitters
swing and a miss
luke jackson just struck out the side
the power slider was vicious tonight
bases are loaded nobody out jorge
solaire the batter three balls two
strikes
and a late swing on a ball in the dirt
that time solaire is retired
and guerra has the first out but now
he's got to face freddie freeman
into right field that's a base hit
that's going to score one here comes
adrianza throw to the plate is gonna be
late
two more rbis for freddie freeman
freddie is just not missing guys
he's putting the ball in play
and how about the throw by para good job
by adrianza
two more runs and we'll take it
runner at first freeman goes the pitch
popped up into shallow right it's going
to hang up forever garcia and para
converge and nearly collide tagging from
third coming home and belly flopping in
safely
ozzy obese
on a sac fly to shallow right not a safe
situation so jesse chavez will come on
and protect a
five run atlanta lead
two on nobody out braves have an eight
to three lead
there's a double play ball
dan's beat to the bag for one and the
first that's number two
and that ball hit right down the line by
garcia
one hopping to the left of the 325 mark
gadiel hernandez home to score
the o2
swing animus what a way to finish it
it's four in a row for the braves who
are now two games over 500.